hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar titled
flow cytometry
as a microbiology tool in the
development of next generation
diagnostics i am michelle ashton of
labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
timothy inglis
dr christine carson and dr kieran
mulrany
from the university of western australia
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction michelle
so i'll get straight into it
and raise the issue of antimicrobial
resistance
or amr now amr
is the silent pandemic we're all used to
the covered pandemic now
but quietly in the background a pandemic
of antimicrobial resistance has been
going on for years
at the moment it is estimated that
approximately
there are 700 000 deaths a year
every year from bacterial infections
that are unable to be effectively
treated by antibiotics
this is the human face of antimicrobial
resistance
and it's getting worse it is estimated
that by
2050 there will be 250 million deaths
from antimicrobial resistance from
infections that simply cannot be treated
by the antibiotics that we have that
currently
take care of those infections
so that means that there will be one
death every three seconds
from drug resistant infections and an
estimated
3 trillion u.s dollars will be lost
in gdp
so how is clinical microbiology going to
address this problem
you have to think of antibiotics as the
fire extinguishers
of human medicine and animal medicine as
well
much of modern medicine is only possible
because we have antibiotics in the wings
in case an infection happens after an
intervention
for example most of modern surgery
relies
on the fact that we can open the human
body
operate on the part that we need to
close it up again
and as long as there is no bacterial
infection
that occurs because of that operation
everything works out fine the patient
is treated effectively their issue is
resolved
and everyone gets to go home the problem
with antimicrobial resistance
is that if at any point during that
surgery
an infection is initiated we're relying
on antibiotics
to treat the infection and to resolve it
now as bacteria become more resistant to
antibiotics
we can no longer rely on the antibiotics
that we've got
to treat those infections effectively so
people may have
knee replacement surgery get a bacterial
infection in
the surgical site and if it's treatable
that's fine if it's not treatable they
could end up dying
of a post-operative bacterial infection
we really really need antibiotics to
support the type of medicine
that we've all want and that we've all
become accustomed to
now up until now broad-spectrum
antibiotics or empirical antibiotics
were the solution that was applied
doctors would look at a surgical site
where they would look at an
infection and they would take their
their very best their well-educated
guess
as to which antibiotics will work to
treat that
infection effectively while they wait
for laboratory data
to come back informing them exactly what
type of
bacterium is there and exactly what its
antimicrobial susceptibility profile is
they take their best well-educated
guests and they apply
a broad spectrum antibiotic that will
inhibit and kill the inhibit the growth
of and kill
most microorganisms but we can overuse
those broad spectrum antibiotics
and each use helps feed the cycle
of inducing resistance so while it is
wonderful to be able to
to use broad spectrum antibiotics the
more we use them
the greater the risk that we're going to
induce antimicrobial
resistance and lose those antibiotics
so against a background of increasing
resistance to antibiotics
the approach of throwing the strongest
antibiotics that we've got
against each infection is going to start
to fail
more and more often and there are
precious few antibiotics in reserve
it's not like once we stop using all the
best antibiotics that we've got
that there are a whole range of other
antibiotics that we can just
slip into that spot and this
untargeted use even initially while
you're waiting for laboratory results
this untargeted use is accelerating the
pace
at which antimicrobial resistance occurs
a concept that is widely discussed now
is the concept of antimicrobial
stewardship
so using the resources that we have the
antibiotics that currently work
using those resources in the best manner
possible
both to treat patients now and to try
and ensure
that we preserve their effectiveness for
future patients
and targeting antimicrobial therapy
specifically
to each patient and their infection is
really important in that process
and that's where antimicrobial
susceptibility tests come in
the faster the better
so to really target that therapy so that
a doctor can take a well-educated guess
as to what antibiotic will work and
patients will probably start on those
antibiotics
but as soon as possible it is very
helpful for the clinician to have
actual laboratory data confirming the
identity
of the organism causing the infection
and confirming its antimicrobial
susceptibility profile
so to actually improve at this process
we need to improve the tests that we
have available to us
the top row on this figure is the
existing
practices that we have so
a sample will come to the laboratory
and on that day while the sample is
going to the laboratory and the
processing of that sample is
beginning the patient if they have a
serious infection is likely to start
antibiotics immediately meanwhile back
at the lab
over the course of the next two to five
days
the organism will hopefully grow in the
laboratory
be identified and be tested against a
range of antibiotics
to identify which one will most
effectively treat the infection
now most of the time the patient gets
better
and the outcome is good but there are
frequently
poor outcomes sometimes the empirical
antibiotics that they'll put on at the
beginning of the process
don't treat the infection that they have
and because it can be two to five days
until you find out what the best
antibiotic is
that makes it very difficult to make
sure that the patient gets to the best
antibiotic
sooner so how do we change that how do
we improve that
obviously part of a new paradigm for
that
is to have better methods that are
more rapid and more accurate
we're probably not going to change in
the short term
that pattern where a patient comes in
and empirical antibiotics are prescribed
on the spot
i doubt that it's going to be a while
before we get in front of that first
dose
but what we can improve is the detection
of
organisms and confirmation that they are
there
identifying what they are and
determining their antimicrobial
susceptibility
ideally it would be preferable
to get that done the same day that the
patient has presented
so they may get a first covering dose of
empirical antibiotics
but then as soon as possible we could
ideally
get them to the optimal antibiotics for
treating their infection and and sort of
one of the holy grails of that area is
same-day decision-making based on data
and we it's our hope that this would
lead to improved
patient outcomes so we really need rapid
culture independent diagnostics so that
we can provide
clinicians with actionable results in in
much quicker time frames
thanks christine so flow cytometry is a
powerful tool
uh for research and can be used
to start to address some of these new
diagnostic challenges
but you need to start somewhere and so
realistically the challenge
for all of this begins long before you
enter a lab and start thinking about
using a flow cytometer
and so the first step in using flow
cytometry
to address some of these challenges is
to identify the difficult biology
that you're looking at and that will
start
straight away with sample preparation a
lot of the time people will come to
these problems and they think okay let's
just we've got a blood sample or we've
got a urine sample
let's just put it through the flow
cytometer and i'm sure that any of the
core facility managers that hear me say
that have probably cringed quite
terribly
because a lot of the time you don't want
to do that you need to think about what
is exactly going on in that sample
before you begin your development
process and that can come down to simple
things like
thinking about non-target particles
within your
sample so if you're looking for bacteria
you've also got to think about all the
other components that might be in there
the human
cells debris chunks of you know
tissue all of those things that are
they're not diagnostically useful for
what you're looking for but could really
damage the flow cytometer by clogs and
those sorts of things
or they could mask your signal and so
one of the best places to start with
that is to be thinking about particle
identity and
the easiest way to do that is go and
grab yourself a microscope look down the
microscope at the sample you're wanting
to work with and say
what can i see do i just see a nice
clear field with a few bacteria and
that's what i want to look for
or is it is it murky is it horrible you
know figure that out
before you take any further steps
because
the other factor of all of this is that
you're still talking about living
organisms when you're talking about
microbiology
and so there are going to be some very
large challenges about the behavior of
those organisms
in those specimens that you need to be
thinking about long before you pick up
a pet and so the next phase would be to
design around those challenges so one of
the best ways that you can start
to identify that is you know if you look
at an etune nxt
as an instrument for uh your development
you have the ability to do accurate
volumetric measurements without the need
for additional counting beats or
anything like that that allows you to do
things
for example like spiking in known
concentrations and looking at what your
signal-to-noise ratios look like and all
of those additional factors
and then that can help you guide with
your reagent selection you know
one of the greatest challenges working
in microbial flow is that we don't have
uh
all of the markers that the
immunologists are used to working on
you know antibodies are not as readily
available and when they are
the coverage across you know ranges and
species is not as great as it could
otherwise be so you need to be thinking
about which dies you're going to use how
you're going to use them
and what that will really do to your
experimental design
and the follow-on from that obviously is
looking at your solutions and your
buffers because if we think back to the
fact that we're
working with living organisms if what
you're looking for in your diagnostic
application or your you know
pre-clinical
development is something that is based
on physiology
not just detection well you need to be
sure that you're not perturbing
the very phenomena that you're trying to
see by using some of your conventional
solutions and buffers and then
to follow from that even further is to
think about the timeline and then
if you're working with a live organism
if you take a measurement and it's a
single measurement
that can be fine but if you're starting
to look for sequential measurements or
you the
the workflow you've designed takes six
hours the difference between where your
sample was
at the end and at the start of those
workflows is it can be very very large
and very impactful
and so once you've made all these
decisions you've developed what you're
going to do
the next step is jump in hypothesize
tests and develop around it so get to
the lab and decide what it is
you're going to do make your first
experiments
and then consider the techniques that
you're going to use with it you know
flow cytometry is very powerful but
you've got to think about all the ways
that you're going to confirm
what it is you're seeing with the flow
and how it is you're going to be sure
that
what you're seeing is what you're
actually assigning
in that sample so precalculation can
help with a lot of that and as i
mentioned before the idea of spiking in
known quantities of organisms and using
the powerful volumetrics of the
instrument to be able to see
exactly what you're measuring compared
to what you expected to measure can tell
you a lot
without having to spend a lot of
reagents and a lot of time in the
laboratory
and then adapt to the data as you see it
there's no point
continuing to throw you know good
reagents after bad
hoping that you're going to get what you
want if the data that's coming out of
your original
assays is not lining up with what you
expect it to
so what i'll do is i'm actually going to
show you a real world example of
you know some technology that we've
developed in our lab and some new assays
that go with it
using the setting of peritoneal dialysis
related
peritonitis and most people will have
given me a blank stare
as to what i'm talking about so i'm
going to give a little background and so
the first thing
you need to know is about end stage
kidney disease which you know
most people know about kidney disease it
is an ever
increasing problem as our population
ages more and more people are needing
support for their kidneys but end stage
disease is where
you've reached the point that your
kidney disease is so severe that you
need some sort of renal replacement
therapy for life
and when it comes to renal replacement
therapy transplantation is the goal for
everyone but not everyone can get organs
whether they don't match or they're
ineligible for transplant and so
dialysis is one of the ways that you
need
to keep those patients supported either
waiting for transplant or if they're
ineligible
as ongoing care and now peritoneal
dialysis
is a form that most people don't know
about
though it is gaining popularity in some
places where instead of
the traditional hemodialysis where you
take a patient
hook up their their blood to a machine
clean it and then put it back
peritoneal dialysis is actually
performed with an indwelling surgical
catheter in the abdomen
and then you can fill the abdominal
cavity with a fluid that all of the
things that your kidneys would normally
filter
will then drain into and then you can
remove it and it's superior in a lot of
ways
patients are not tethered to a chair for
their dialysis session
they can go about their life they can do
all the things that they want to do
but there is a real risk associated with
that and that main complication is
peritonitis which is an
infection of that abdominal cavity that
largely comes about because you have
this indwelling surgical catheter
and that complication is driving people
away from it
so right now the only way that we test
is using culture-based techniques we
take the fluid that comes out and we say
does this grow an organism yes or no
and unfortunately even with the best
available practices
in about 20 of cases that doesn't grow
anything
even when there is clinical presentation
and
the the observations may meet the
guidelines for the diagnosis of
peritonitis your patient clearly has an
infection
but 20 cases you've got nothing to work
with
so that really needs us to look at what
we're going to do because right now as
christine mentioned earlier empirical
antibiotic therapies
the way that it is treated a patient
presents the clinician will look at it
and say that is
an infection and then they will give
very extreme antibiotic regimes because
you can't take the risk
that you know those patients are going
to be fine until the lab
tells you something maybe days later
the current best estimates from clinical
data suggest that every hour that you go
without
effective antimicrobial therapy 6.4
risk of death that's unacceptable so we
need to start looking at better
treatments
so any diagnostic that will enable those
treatments and with targeted
antimicrobial therapy
must be both very very rapid and very
accurate we need to be able to get
just a really rapid turnaround and we
need to be able to have absolute
confidence because if you get it wrong
and they get inappropriate therapy
there's a very good chance that patient
would die
and then the reason we've turned to flow
cytometry to start addressing some of
these challenges in our development
is that uh pcr and other nucleic acid
amplification based tests have
completely failed to solve the issue
and there is an entire you know lecture
series on exactly why that is
but we'll see some of the reasons as we
look at what we've done with flow
cytometry
so what we did you know in line with
those early
philosophy statements i made about how
to do the design
is that we kept it very simple when we
started we had uh
specimens provided under a biobank
arrangement
where we could start to do some of this
testing and we could start to
look at you know what was going on in
there so we used very simple uh
cleanup techniques we centrifuge based
uh
rather than chemical because we really
wanted to see if we could get some of
those living organisms out of there
and then we selected two dyes to work
with so we're working with cyto9 which
is a nucleic acid binding dye that will
allow us to say
yes that particle has dna in it and then
also
the live dead fixable violet viability
stain because that will allow us to get
an
understanding about whether a particle
we're looking at a contains
protein uh because of the way that the
dye
binds and b also will come back and say
whether or not that it's
alive or dead and then we just
allow those to go and then put the whole
thing through the flow cytometer
to get a view of what are we actually
seeing
and when we did that we had a
populations that come with a great big
smear that doesn't really look
particularly informative
so we had to then build a hypothesis
around what it is we thought we were
seeing
so we looked at the very very you know
higher forward scatter and side scatters
well okay the largest particles are
probably human cells so this cluster up
the top is probably our human cells
and then we went okay there's there
appears to be this second cluster that's
down the bottom that we say okay that's
probably where the bacterial cells are
going to be sitting
and anyone that looks at that hypothesis
says okay great you know
what how are you going to tell us
anything about that and so
we then took it and we were wearing some
electron microscopy and we said actually
look you can see
there are human cells through all of
this and that was confirmed with some
cd45 staining to show that yes those are
white cells that are there
and then we also went through and we
found that that sample was full of
bacteria as well
so it does give us some confidence to
say well
probably you know that that's likely
what you're looking at
and that enabled us to say well let's
start seeing what better we can do with
this data
to get a little more confidence in what
we're seeing
and so we ran through a cleanup
procedure through our gating to to start
making some choices about saying well
what events are going to be the most
important and which arms so
this is using an aliquot that's been
unstained first of all and we have our
pro uh a profile by ford and side
scatter on the left
and so we said well we only really care
about those particles that contain
nucleic acids so let's throw in a cyto9
positive gate and say anything that is
in this gate
that's positive so once you apply that
gate to an unstained sample
you'll find that yes there's a few
little auto fluorescent events left and
some of the human cells
that have been left in after our cleanup
procedure right up the top
on that uh top of that axis you can see
but for the most part we're not seeing
anything that's going to be staining so
we can be
reasonably confident that if we use a
stained
control anything that we're seeing there
is staining positive
and so this is again with a same
presentation but with sustained controls
and you can see that once you apply that
cyto9 positive gate there really
is you know a couple of populations that
jump out and we'll start addressing what
some of that might mean
uh momentarily but if you then back gate
that across you'll see that you actually
have removed quite a considerable amount
of this low forward scatter and low side
scatter background events
uh but interestingly there are still
seeming to be
multiple populations in this and we'll
address that a little later as well
so once we reach that point we know just
clean it up make sure there's no
aggregates left
now we designed our protocol so that we
shouldn't see aggregates because we
didn't want to make anyone mad by
clogging a flow cytometer
but that being said the tuna nxt is
really robust and doesn't
tend to clog at all but why take a
chance so
conventional sides gotta hide by side
scatter area just to say okay there's no
doublets and clusters in any of all of
this
and then we went and looked at the the
uh fixable amine
uh violet stain and so we see you know
on an unstained control
you get a little bit of that human cell
stuff bleeding through again
but then if you look you get this viable
population and then you get
your sec double population up the top in
your non-viable gate
where you'll see uh if there are dead
cells that's where they'll come in
so by the time we layer on all of those
uh
gates once we've got looked at you know
our forward and side our cyto9
our viability stain we get to a place
where we've got a decent cleaned up
population that we can start to
enumerate and start just
asking some questions about some of
those uh the volumetric comparisons that
we can make
you know how many events are in this
versus that and start to do some more
powerful things with it
so the first thing that we needed to do
before we started jumping onto
human samples is we needed to test those
assumptions and so what we've done
is we've run through a whole bunch of
different microbial control strains
where we've lined up the conventional
spot based
agar plate counting method
and the slow cytometry to be able to say
well if we measure
x number of cells by flow cytometry does
the conventional method line up to it
and what you can see with all of this
and if you run the statistics that go
with it there is
a little bit of a bias towards the flow
cytometry over counting
not in all cases but as a general rule
that's what you'll see
which is okay as long as you understand
that bias
when you're moving forward you know it's
entirely possible that there
are a whole range of reasons we could be
seeing that but as long as we know
what that bias looks like and the assay
we've designed is internally
self-consistent
the fact that it is close and it is
close you know it's within
an order of magnitude which for
microbiology is pretty good
uh that's probably you know sufficient
for us to continue downstream
so once we got to this point we said
well what we are calling a microbial
cell
by flow cytometry using all of those
indices that we've measured for the
staining
lines up pretty well with what we see on
an agar plate which is our conventional
gold standard evidence
so we can be pretty thrilled with that
so let's take it to
processing some of these samples that
are coming from
the real world from and see what that
actually looks like
and so what we ended up seeing was uh if
you compare the three
separate classifications number one was
a patient who has no clinical suspicion
of
infection which we'll call uninfected we
have patients who have culture negative
peritonitis where they meet those
definitions for an
infection but no nothing could be grown
in the clinical laboratory
and then culture positive where you have
an infection
and they grew a causative organism in
the laboratory
so for the uninfected uh we had uh
patients
and the subjects under our ethics that
were in
the hospital for reasons completely
unrelated to their dialysis
and so we took a sample there and we
were able to
uh run that through an assay and we
found that in those we found roughly ten
to the four cells per mil
and which was quite startling to begin
with but uh
hold on to that thought and we'll come
back to it
and then in the culture negative oh
sorry
before we move on of the in one of those
which is the little uh
hat sitting on the top of that
uninfected we actually did take it to a
clinical
to our research laboratory and we
cultured a staff epidermis out of it
itself
i've left it in the data because i think
it's an interesting observation
but technically uh by the the
definitions
we shouldn't actually consider that not
an infection
but then we start to ask some of these
questions and the uninfected and the
culture negative
really start to drive this home which
says you know we've got our viability
state in there so
if it says that the cells are viable why
can't we culture them then because we
know that there are infections involved
we know that we've seen the evidence of
them by
electron microscopy and by the flow
cytometry
so what's going on there that that's you
know a bit of a head scratcher
and then loop it back to this infected
if we're saying that there's
10 to the four cells per mil in these
patients
what is going on you know are sterile
sites ever truly sterile and so just by
even trying to develop this diagnostic
we've come through and said
this is this is potentially something
huge it's something we need to
investigate we need to know
more about the biology and the power of
that comes from
not only really good design before you
hit the laboratory
but also from using you know
a high precision instrument with good
internal reproducibility
so you can get this accurate cell
counting that goes with it
so once we got all of this and we've got
116 patients worth of data there we
asked the question well
is good enough good enough when it comes
to a prediction about whether or not
someone has an infection
and at our best you know across this 116
uh sample range we found an 88
prediction of sense uh for sensitivity
saying you know
of all of the actual infection cases we
can pick up 88
of them and 94 specificity which says if
the new
the new test says that this this is
potentially an infection
is that you know does that line up uh
and so in that case you're seeing you
know six percent of a potential
false positive so
you've got to take that back to the real
world before you make any assumptions
because
like i said before a new test in this
setting would have to be
nearly perfect and 88 sensitivity
really doesn't sound like it's good
enough
until you think back to the real world
context and when i said before that
if you've got 20 percent that are
culture negative
so the existing diagnostics comes back
and says there's nothing here
that means that already we're eight
percent better at picking up an
infection than that so
is it perfect no is it better than
what's currently used
well actually yes so from there we're
moving forward with pre-clinical trials
for all of this we want we want to
really understand
where that place in a potential workflow
would sit and start to look at answering
some of those questions you know really
is it really that good
if you don't know the infection state
before you're going into it
can it uh can it do what it needs to do
and start to look at some of like the
health economic questions you know ask
is it worth spending all this money on a
new way of doing this
to help patients now we clearly believe
that it will and
you know early modelling does suggest
that that's the case but
if you want to you know start to
translate some of your
discoveries into real world practice
knowing that it's actually going to make
a difference is
everything and then you need to be
thinking about you know the validation
of all of your
analysis you know you can't just take
something that worked really good in a
research setting in a laboratory
and run with it to try to you know give
results to clinicians and doctors
it's a terrible idea because of the risk
involved to begin with but also
there are regulations that need to be
adhered to
and if you would ever to think that you
wanted to do that there are
very high bars that you have to meet for
your regulatory validation to be able to
get there
so it's one of those things that
everyone wants to do better but you do
really need to think about
you know the steps that are taken when
you're designing
so as a sneak peek uh i i'm not
satisfied yet
i'm still designing for perhaps a second
generation and so
many people familiar with flow will see
the plot on the left here and see you
know t-sne
as a way to separate populations out in
their their relatedness to each other
and their differences from other
populations
and so we started taking some some data
and pushing it through
and looking at how the algorithms
determine these clusters
and anyone that looks at the overlay
flow plot who's familiar with all of
your
uh human cell subset stuff is going to
start to
to pick out a few shapes that they they
think they recognize
but what i found most interesting with
this is we go back to this cluster one
in green
uh that is what we are saying in
microbial cells and if you take
the data from that and look at that but
it says we say it's a microbial cell
with our flow method and then you take
some control e coli and staph aureus and
then you overlay it all
actually you'll find that that
population fits really really nicely
with the bacteria
so we're still working the quest will
never be over when it comes to
developing better
and with fancier tools but this is where
some of our new horizons will look like
so what i'll do is i'll change gears a
little bit because we want to look even
further down
that potential pathway so we can go okay
yes we can look at this and we can
say whether or not there is an infection
but now we want to know
what drug is going to work and so our
lab has developed what we call
the flow cytometry assisted
antimicrobial susceptibility test or
fast for short
and that is been designed rationally to
fit into
microbiology workflows that people are
used to once you've got a specimen
you then you know will make a mcfarland
standard like is already done
in research laboratories around the
world you then use an automated
inoculator
to inoculate uh an antimicrobial plate
and rather than you know
the traditional method which would be 24
to 48 hours of
incubation depending on the organism
we're only exposing for two to three
hours in this case
and then we will use that auto
inoculator again to add our stains
and then put it through the auto sampler
on the etune
to give us you know a full plate read in
less than an hour
and then we have some software
prototypes that will give us our reports
of all of the
appropriate indices less than two
minutes after that
so in a brief tour of how this works you
know once we've gone through
the antimicrobial exposure and we've put
it all through the flow cytometer
we get this data in the middle which
will give us our
our healthy unexposed uh distribution so
we can say
this is what this bacterial isolate
looks like
as it was put through the flow cytometer
with no drug insult
and then we can use some clustering and
gating
to be able to draw this purple bounded
region on the right hand panel which we
call the antimicrobial
unexposed population or aup and we're
able to make some measurements both of
the distribution
and we're showing forward by cyto9 here
however we do have other channels that
are involved and then we can also
using the volumetrics we can say this is
how many events per microliter we see
and so once we know what healthy
actively dividing cells look like
well we can we can start to see what is
a drug going to do
so to demonstrate this quickly and
powerfully what we've got
is uh klebsiella pneumoniae which is a
pathogen of
uh quite large international concern
and we're using the drug meropenem which
is one of the
last drugs uh in an escalation pathway
so on the left-hand side we've got atcc
70603 which is a control
susceptible strain and then we've got
k14
which is an extremely resistant clinical
strain
and so in each of them we've we've gone
through the method we've put the the
data through the flow cytometer and
we've bounded that region of the aup so
you know that this is where healthy
cells will sit 200 per microliter on the
left
326 per microliter on the right this is
with no meropenum
and then if we look at what happens when
you add the smallest amount you can
immediately see the difference the
susceptible has dropped down to 12
per microliter and has already shifted
most of the events
that still exist outside that gate
whereas the resistance
really hasn't changed much at all and so
we can keep pushing more drug
concentrations so
one we start to see these multiple
populations emerging
almost all of them outside that healthy
aup region and on the right hand side
still not much and so once we get to
four
uh milligrams per liter here if you're
not
susceptible here you're not clinically
susceptible you can't use meropenem
which is great but what we wanted to see
is can we make the
resistance strain do what the
susceptible strain does
if we throw enough drug at it and
actually if you keep going
16 on the right hand side 64 we start to
see some movement
at 128 that population is almost
entirely out of the gate
and then at 256 you start to see it you
see that
that hook shape that you see on the left
is starting to evolve there and that's
actually where
that isolate is susceptible meaningless
from a clinical perspective because if
you put that much meropenem
into a human you'll also kill the human
and not the bacteria
but that does allow us to see where we
are
and so from there we've actually found
that you can do this for many many many
strains
and species of bacteria so this is with
staph aureus you know
this is an mrsa and you'll see the
gentamycin and the vancomycin which are
two clinically relevant
drugs both they have you know a
susceptible phenotype by flow cytometry
and in the resistant you can still see
the persistence of that population
and this is caphoxatin which is used to
screen for an mrsa
and with the k-nemonia again other drug
classes will give you similar phenomena
as you go through so this is actually
widely applicable
across many many many drugs i think at
last count we're at 13 classes of
antimicrobials
and many many species of bacteria and
fungi
and other organisms of import
to four peritoneal dialysis samples we
actually went through and we tested
uh five specimens of each of these
different
species klebsiella e coli pseudomonas
aeriginosa
staph aureus and staphobitaminous which
represent the most common
infections in that setting and what we
found is that the agreement was actually
very good
so we have essential agreement which is
agreement with the
the reference method within the
resolution of the reference method
and then categorical agreement which is
what is shown in the heat map which says
if the existing test says it's sensitive
does the new test stay sensitive yes if
it's resistant by the old test
is the new test states resistant yes and
you'll find that yes there are a few
minor errors which are
listed in the blue and then a few where
the calls are not quite there
but these numbers are actually where a
test needs to be
at the most stringent levels of
performance
and you'll actually find that the the
overall variance across all of
the tested results is usually very very
good
most of them are exactly the same if
we're saying the
the minimum inhibitory concentration of
drug
measured by one method is exactly the
same as registered by the new method
and then a little bit of variance but
majority
agreement and so again
you need to go through and you need to
line up as many samples as you can to be
certain that all of your validation is
doing
exactly what it needs to do that you're
meeting those performance indices that
could potentially be required
if you were to look at moving the next
step
actually into the laboratory and getting
regulatory validation for all of those
things
and then health economics again is a
huge part of all of this you know if you
want to run all of these new fancy
things you would need to be able to say
yes this will make a real world impact
and pre-clinical studies
without intervention are the place to go
to for all of that
so to round us up in the cemetery you
know in a summary
we gotta start with the psychometrist
law everyone knows it you put garbage in
you're gonna get garbage out so you've
really got to be certain and the best
way that you do that
is doing those initial activities where
you go through your rational design
before you get to the lab
you validate everything that you're
going to be doing and you'll be certain
with you know additional analyses like
microscopy
electron microscopy all of those other
things that say what
we're seeing by flow really does
correlate with what we can see with
other evidence
and then just you know to follow on from
that design with intent
know your problem really well you know
you can't just take
a sample throw it through a flow
cytometer and expect that what you're
going to get out on the other end is
going to be great
you need to know what's in your sample
you need to know what you're looking for
and you need to really thought through
how to enable
the the assay that happens to make sure
that your flow cytometry data is going
to be the best it can be
and so we've proven that you can use
flow cytometry to address these
previously interactable challenges you
know it can be done
but it does require this extra level of
rigor and
real-world validation from those extra
tools to be sure what you're looking at
is
is really what's happening and so we've
developed
demonstrated these innovative
applications you know we can detect
infection really really rapidly and we
can get these susceptibility profiles
out within that three to five you know
hour window which means
that whole workflow comes back to that
same day
testing paradigm that christine was
talking about earlier in our
presentation
so flow cytometry is a powerful tool
that could potentially address
all of these uh challenges
and really we're coming back to is the
phenotype and we haven't
labeled the point in depth here but that
you know the flowchart
the power of the flow cytometry in all
of this is that we're still measuring
live organisms and so we can be looking
at all of those phenotypic
expression as we're going through we
don't have to have
you know either just nucleic acid and
hope for the best that we can tell
what's being expressed and what isn't
and we don't have to you know have fixed
cells and just hope that what we're
seeing
is going to be enough we actually have
you know real-time
profiling of the phenotype as things
happen in the tube
and then translation and regulation is
is one of those things that
you know we don't talk about very much
and we probably just should do a lot
more
if you want to be able to take really
you know fun and interesting
discoveries that you've got in the lab
and you want to make something out of
them in the real world
you've got to be thinking about you know
how do you translate this
where where is the use case and then
regulatory validation
you know everything we've shown you
today is you know research use only but
there is a pathway in jurisdictions
around the world for
really using some of these innovations
but you've got to be
designing with intent to get there as
you go
and you've got to be engaging with the
experts to be able to say
you know we can do this or actually you
know you've got to start again and
you've got to rethink it
so all of these tools have have promise
and we have
i hopefully have shown you some
demonstrations of just how powerful they
can be
but there's still that step into real
world translation that we want to be
taking
and you know we're encouraging other
people to be thinking that way too
cytometry is a great tool but we can do
more with it
if we all work along the right lines
and so uh i'll round off there but
there's a huge number of people that we
need to thank for all of
this work uh particularly the
translational renal research group
uh associate professor aaron shakira who
runs that
uh and has been a great mentor to me as
we've been developing these
assays and then through the fast lab uh
associate professor tim inglis
christine who spoke to you before and
then
the rest of the team who have been
toiling away at all of these
uh innovations for many years now and
then you know
the university of western australia path
west the harry perkins institute and
demo fisher scientific who have been
gracious in allowing us to speak today
and to
communicate our findings to you so at
this point
i'll hand back over to our moderator
thank you dr carson and dr mueller for
your informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started
let's see our first question
is is there scope for the dyes and
stains
used in microbial flow cytometry to be
further developed
ah yes great question and one that i'm a
little bit uh
rabidly passionate about myself so i did
mention briefly earlier about
you know how underprivileged poor
microbiologists are when it comes to new
dyes
and new tools you know with the changes
in cell envelope that come with
different strains of bacteria we can't
rely on antibodies as our primary method
of detection
and quite often you will find that
taking dyes out of the catalog that were
originally intended
for eukaryotic human cell use in
particular
they will not behave the same with
microorganisms
uh you'll find that you know a single
cellular living organism
does a whole bunch of things differently
than a cell within a tissue
and so but there are many great tools
out there
you do need to think about the way that
they're going to act
with the different physiology and the
different structures that go with it
and so there's there's both a lot of
potential in taking existing dyes off
the shelf and repurposing them
if you understand the microbiology and
understand that
the activity that you see is likely to
be very different
than you would expect from some of the
eukaryotic stuff
but there's also probably a lot of room
for development and there's been
a lot of innovation particularly over
the last five to ten years where there's
a lot of new chemistry and a lot of
unique ways to look at these things so
i'm really excited about where the
future for that may go and i know a lot
of other people are as well
thank you next question is are there
methods
in environmental microbiology that could
be replaced
by flow cytometric methods
so i'll take that question i think that
there are a number of methods
in environmental microbiology that could
be replaced with
both cytometric methods and again it
comes down to that
question of understanding the biology of
the organisms that you're trying to
detect
and in many cases in environmental
microbiology the organisms that you're
trying to
count so by thinking very clearly about
the intent
of the existing tests and the biology of
the organisms involved
i think it is possible to design
alternative tests that use flow
cytometric methods
to detect and enumerate those organisms
now of course you would have to
navigate the regulatory sphere which is
not trivial
you know there are often local municipal
state
national and international guidelines
that must be met around these questions
so
it's it's definitely possible to do some
of these things by flow cytometry
it's where the people have the
enthusiasm
to get them across the line at a
regulatory level
great thank you now do you think flow
cytometry will gradually
infiltrate the microbiology laboratory
i think that flow cytometry has already
begun to infiltrate the microbiology
laboratory so
particularly in research in diagnostic
settings
we're starting to see flow cytometry
used for the processing
of urines urine specimens um so in
research it's
it's much easier to incorporate flow
cytometry
into the methods that you want to use to
study a particular problem
because there isn't the regulation and
the
validation requirements around using the
instruments
and the techniques and i that
sort of frees people up to explore i
guess
the applications that they may be able
to use flow cytometry for
i think eventually they will slow cetera
will be used
in a greater role in clinical
microbiology laboratories
but there's a lot of work between where
we are now
and getting to that stage meanwhile you
know it's very easy
to apply flow cytometry in research
laboratories
thank you dr carson okay we've time for
one more question
why isn't flow cytometry used more
widely
in diagnostic microbiology
well as karen has articulated very
clearly
you know the biology of the organisms
involved
in the kinds of tests that we need is
quite complex
the um in the clinical microbiology
laboratory the specimens that come in
you know the sample matrix they vary
considerably depending on what
specimen you're dealing with you know
urine is very different to a peritoneal
dialysis fluid
which is very different from a blood
sample and the complexity
of the those sample matrices
needs you need to consider all of that
when you're designing your tests
and unless you are designing from the
ground up
with the intent to use it in a
diagnostic
application it's very easy to take wrong
terms along the way
so the potential for a flow cytometry to
be used
more in diagnosis certainly exists
that now needs to be translated into you
know accurate sensitive specific
diagnostic tests that can meet all the
validation requirements
and that's not a trivial task uh you
know it's achievable
but it would require a lot of very
focused
dedicated work to achieve that outcome
well thank you again dr christine carson
and dr karen mulverney for your time
today
we would also like to thank labrutz and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and further interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time